James Bond is one of the all-time great
movie characters: he's suave, he's tough,
and he's got a fashion sense to die for.
But what's the real story behind the scenes
of Britain's most iconic film franchise?
This is the untold truth of James Bond.
Before there were the James Bond movies,
there were the James Bond novels.
Written by Ian Fleming, the 14 Bond books
were a kind of fantasy version of Fleming's
real-life experiences as a member of British Naval
Intelligence. The author was a total unknown when
Casino Royale was set to be published, but he was
determined to make his book a hit, and routinely
sent out signed copies of his book to as many
newspaper and magazine editors as he could.
Despite his efforts, however, the book still
wasn't selling well — especially in America.
But everything changed when Fleming came across
the perfect opportunity to get his name out there.
After the Suez Crisis, the British Prime Minister
Anthony Eden's health had begun to deteriorate,
and he soon found himself in need of a place
to relax. Always one to take an opportunity,
Fleming eagerly offered the politician access
to Goldeneye, his secluded home in Jamaica.
The author was thrilled by the visit, hoping
Eden's stay at Goldeneye would boost the sales
of his book. And believe it or not, the
crazy publicity stunt actually worked,
thrusting Fleming into the public eye and
making his stories famous around the world.
Growing up in New York, Albert "Cubby" Broccoli
worked on his uncle's farm, which primarily grew
the family's signature vegetable, broccoli.
But young Cubby didn't want to spend his
entire life working in the dirt, so he took his
chances and moved to Hollywood in the 1930s.
After slowly working his way up the industry,
Broccoli ended up co-producing the first feature
film adaptation of Ian Fleming's James Bond spy
novels. During his search for the titular hero,
Broccoli heard an actor named Sean Connery
might be a good choice for the role,
so he went to see the Scotsman in
Darby O'Gill and the Little People.
Broccoli was impressed with Connery's
work on the movie, but wondered if the
actor had the raw sex appeal needed for Bond
— so he showed his his wife the film, too.
She, of course, made it clear that Connery
was more than capable in this department.
Though the movie's studio, United Artists,
threw around a number of names for the role,
Broccoli fought for Connery and won — and so began
one of the longest running film series in history.
"I admire your luck, Mr…" "Bond. James Bond."
Though Sean Connery is typically known as the
first proper Bond, two other actors actually
played the role before him. In 1954, CBS
paid Fleming $1,000 for the rights to
Casino Royale and turned the novel into a
one-hour TV special for the series Climax!
For the first glimpse of Bond in
the flesh, they cast Barry Nelson,
an actor who has starred in a ton of TV shows in
his time. But you'll probably recognize him best
as Stuart Ullman, the guy who hires Jack Nicholson
to take care of the Overlook Hotel in The Shining.
After the TV version, a South African radio
station produced an adaptation of Moonraker,
featuring the vocal talents of Bob Holness. If
you're American, that name might not mean much,
but if you're from the UK, you'd know
him as the host of various game shows,
particularly of the long running, Trivial
Pursuit-like show Blockbusters. Luckily,
the idea of game show hosts playing James
Bond doesn't seem to have become a tradition.
So, there's been an Irish Bond. There's been a
Scottish Bond. There was even an Australian Bond,
albeit briefly. But to this day, an American
has never donned the tuxedo for a feature film…
although one came incredibly close.
After filming For Your Eyes Only,
Roger Moore was ready to
turn in his license to kill,
and James Brolin was one of the top choices
to replace the British star for Octopussy.
Despite his American accent, Brolin perfected his
British-isms so well that he was even tentatively
offered the role for a short amount of time.
Unfortunately for Brolin, Roger Moore decided
to come back to the franchise after all, killing
any dreams of an American Bond. Maybe one day.
Having opened in 1935, Pinewood Studios has
been with Bond since the very beginning.
But during their 60 years of filming there,
the franchise's cast and crew have endured
their fair share of disasters. In 1984, the
stage on which most of the Bond films were shot
tragically burned to the ground. It took a
full year to rebuild, and it was eventually
renamed as the "Albert R. Broccoli 007
Stage," in honor of the legendary producer.
Unfortunately, the 007 Stage burned down again
in 2006. At the time, the 007 Stage was actually
being used for a Bond movie, and the blaze
ended up destroying the fake Venice used in
Casino Royale. Luckily, the filmmakers had just
finished shooting, no one was hurt, and there
weren't any dangerous pyrotechnics or flammable
objects around to make things worse. Even so,
it took around 90 minutes to get the fire under
control. By 2007, the 007 Stage was open again,
newly enlarged, and now it's one of
the biggest sound stages in Europe.
James Bond has always pulled out the
stops when it comes to theme songs.
Among the legendary artists who have written
for the franchise are Shirley Bassey,
Paul McCartney, Madonna, Gladys Knight,
Carly Simon, Tom Jones, and… Ace of Base?
Yes, indeed, the 90s Swedish pop group Ace of Base
was actually hired to write a Bond theme — for
Pierce Brosnan's Bond debut, GoldenEye. Sadly,
the head honchos at Arista Records, the label
that represented the band, thought GoldenEye was
going to be a flop, and they didn't want their
primo band associated with failure. So Arista
pulled Ace of Base from the project, and the
James Bond folks went with Tina Turner instead.
However, the Swedish band did rename their track
"The Juvenile," and if you're interested, you
can still hear the 007 song that could've been.
A number of other famous artists have written Bond
themes over the years, too, only to fall at the
final hurdle. Blondie were locked-in to pen the
title track to For Your Eyes Only for a while,
Johnny Cash wrote his own version of Thunderball,
and Pulp almost did the theme for Tomorrow Never
Dies. Even Radiohead almost got in on the Bond
action, writing a title track for Spectre that,
sadly, was rejected by producers — because it
was, in their opinion, too dark for the movie.
After Sean Connery left the franchise, the
producers were adamant that they should find
the perfect replacement for him. But
nobody could have guessed it would be
George Lazenby , the Australian car mechanic who
fell into male modeling. According to Lazenby,
he had never acted in his life, but when he got
the info about auditions during a threesome,
the man decided he would work as hard
as he could to win the producers over.
Over the next four months, they made
him jump through a number of hoops,
including a screen test with a wrestler
who Lazenby accidentally knocked out.
Then, in a genuinely shocking move, the producers
sent him a sex worker to make sure he wasn't gay.
"This never happened to the other fella."
Given that he allegedly ended up sleeping
with almost every girl on set, however,
it seems like Lazenby passed that
particularly disturbing test.
In fact, Lazenby actually did well with his
first Bond film, On Her Majesty's Secret Service,
and was even offered a $1 million contract to
star in six more movies… but his agent at the
time told him to turn it down. According
to his agent, the Bond age was over,
and people were more into gritty films, like
Easy Rider. So Lazenby left Bond behind — and
was eternally blackballed for being a nobody
that turned down the biggest franchise around.
Roger Moore was a man of many
talents. Not only did he play 007,
but he has also written about the iconic
spy, too. In his book, Bond on Bond,
Moore gives ample insight into the world of Ian
Fleming's character. And while Moore provides
all sorts of interesting behind-the-scenes
details, he drops one informational nugget
that's particularly surprising. Though
the franchise has flourished for years,
Moore says that, during his time playing Bond,
he got by largely without the help of a script.
Back in Moore's day, before shooting began,
the basic plot was laid out and the action set
pieces were in place — but all that
snappy dialogue was constantly changing,
from the first read to the final shooting dates.
Often, while on set with director Lewis Gilbert,
Moore would have his lines memorized and ready
to go — when Gilbert would suddenly decide they
could do better, and basically flush the script
down the toilet. And while Moore admits that this
was probably frustrating for the screenwriters,
he also suggests that the paychecks
were big enough to make up for it.
Timothy Dalton was one of the top
choices to replace Sean Connery in 1969,
but Dalton himself felt he was
too young for the role. Luckily,
the producers didn't forget his name, and by the
time Roger Moore decided to leave the series,
they had swung back around to Dalton.
Since it'd been almost 20 years since
the first request, Dalton finally felt
he was old enough to take on the role.
The Welsh actor played a much less comedic
version of 007 in The Living Daylights and
Licence to Kill, and he was all set to do a
third — but a legal dispute put the film on
hold and released Dalton from his contractual
obligations. When the studio was ready to start
up the franchise again, Dalton had decided
he only wanted to return one last time — but,
after such a long wait between movies,
the producers wanted a Bond who would
stick around for a while. So Dalton
passed the torch to the next fella.
While Pierce Brosnan first donned the James Bond
suit for GoldenEye, he was actually meant to
show up a little bit earlier. The Irish actor was
first offered the role for The Living Daylights,
but he couldn't get out of his TV contract for
Remington Steele. Fortunately, the producers came
back around to Brosnan when he was conflict-free.
But while he brought a new energy to the
franchise, Brosnan never felt happy with his
performance as Bond. As the man himself put it:
"I felt I was caught in a time warp between
Roger [Moore] and Sean [Connery]. [...] The
violence was never real, the brute
force of the man was never palpable.
It was quite tame, and the characterization didn't
have a follow-through of reality, it was surface.
But then that might have had to do with my
own insecurities in playing him as well."
As the latest actor to play James Bond,
Daniel Craig has plenty of mixed feelings
about the iconic role. He takes the films
seriously and loves the work, of course,
but also once called the role "a drag"
and has occasionally insisted he wants
nothing less than to never play the
role again. More recently, however,
he has walked back those comments, calling his
gig as the super spy the best job in the world.
So what's up the mixed emotions? Well,
maybe Craig feels so conflicted because
Bond is his complete opposite.
As the actor once told TimeOut:
"I was aware of what was needed to
be Bond, but it still goes against
everything I believe in. You've met me
a couple of times, I'm not very cool."
But Bond has to be cool, he goes on to
say, and that often feels awkward for him.
Though you'd never guess that Daniel Craig
thinks he's kind of a dork, it's easy to
understand the pressure of playing the smoothest
character in film history. Still, if the popular
reception to his Bond is anything to go by, Craig
really doesn't have anything to worry about.
[https://youtu.be/xsNIGJdxws8?t=114 1:54
to 1:58 - The name's Bond. James Bond."]
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.